[Music]
hi rob this is terry from minneapolis
hey thanks so much for doing the podcast
i listen to a lot of podcasts and yours
is my favorite probably because i think
you're a very good host
like you i've been sober for many years
and i really appreciate hearing your
insights on recovery and my question is
have you ever played a character who was
an alcoholic or addict and if so did
your personal experiences help with the
role
thanks so much and keep up the good work
well terry
first of all thank you for for
super kind words and and i really
appreciate hearing
from from folks um that they like the
show it really means a lot to me truly
does so thank you for that
so bro i have got a little piece of
filmography for you to go
watch to answer your question
i did a movie
um
oh my god
i did a movie called i melt with you
it is a very obscure
indie
shoestring budget by the great director
mark pellington
who is known
for his music videos with rem and um
uh
pearl jam and on and on and on
and
it's the story of addiction it's a it's
a it's a movie about
a group of men
who are going through midlife crisis
and are on a drug bender together on an
isolated
um rented bnb airbnb on the big sur
coast
i will
warn
you that
it is the darkest
movie you may ever see
and my character is a um
a doctor
who is also prescribing drugs to people
and
i do more pills and blow and drink and
i'm up all night and girls show up and
it's just on and on and on and it it
you know i was probably 25 years sober
when i made it and i
felt high
shot all night long three nights like in
a row
music and dancing and it was very
small crew and
by the time
there were times when i was like this
feels so real to me
and
sort of to be if i could be totally
honest kind of exciting
and
wildly depressing
all all at once it's not for everyone it
bears the honor of having the most
uh legendary screening at
sundance film festival
i think 30 percent of the audience
walked out it's one of those movies that
when i read the script i was like if we
do this right
half of the people in any given audience
will walk out
that's how dark it is
but it's super good and i'm super proud
of it uh but it is not for everyone
um anyway so there's that and you know
you're always asked to play drunk you
know that always happens
um my biggest fear is that they uh
when i ask for non-alcoholic beer that
they give me real beer and that's
happened a couple of times but you know
look as i've said a number of times you
know being um in recovery for as long as
i have been has has made me a way better
actor way better person way better
everything so anytime i get to hear a
fellow brother or sister out there
checking in congratulations on your
recovery and um if you know as always if
anybody's out there struggling there is
tons of hope and there is tons of uh
successful stories of people whose lives
changed and i'm sending you all prayers
and thank you for calling